reject Nation if there were a hall of
fame for Digital entertainment I'd be
its proud curator introducing you to the
P g2a gate 2 Adventure believe me it's
the adventure terminal that even Legends
speak of so what's GTA secret sauce
imagine a world where Netflix marathons
swiping right on Tinder epic game
showdowns and even that Amazon shopping
spree all converge and hey if you're
thinking software GTA is got that
digital magic too but wait there's more
the prices are so slashed they'd make a
discount store plush and the instant
delivery faster than a wink from yours
truly now brace yourselves cuz g2a is
pulling all stops for their birthday
bash if your basket in the USA Sunshine
gaming laptops in an entire year of free
games backing you it's almost as good as
a day in my Entourage I definitely have
friends in summary dive head first into
g2a gate 2 Adventure bask in digital
Glory grab those deals and remember if
it's on g2a it's bound to be legendary
much like some people we know wink I
definitely have a
friend
citizens of the reject nation is time
for Loki season 2 episode thr today jge
how are you doing I'm ready for
moas all right Koy how you do lowkey
excited lowkey oh yeah that's you really
demonstrated that with your 10 a Mobius
pun I felt pressure ladies and gentlemen
you know what to do prune that like
button or no don't take it away that'd
be terrible and uh subscribe click the
notification Bell to get if I want to
reaction for the next episode is up here
on this Chanel as always full length
Reaction watch along so you sync up with
your own copy of Loki available for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
thank you to all who have joined already
becoming super sexy Rejects and over
there we cover several things
exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs included let's explore the
Multiverse containment doors are locked
and only the person who designed it can
open it with a Liv scan of his temporal
Aura they're going to need to get Victor
timely for that maybe Victor timley is
an evil cuz he hasn't developed it yet I
don't think he's going to be evil think
he's going to be a guy I think he's
going to have good intentions he's going
to be like uh miles
Dyson I think you're right feels Victor
timely I mean yeah feels like it's from
that era I hope he's playing jazzy good
time perfect rendition I love it I never
thought we'd hear this rag Time marel
theme who's that guy who does the grop
cheese or whatever Richard Cheese Rich
Che this is delightful new
ringtone rag time Marvel Suite here for
it that
Rona
yep where is
she she are you looking for
you what took you so long seems so
obvious what am I doing here I'll don't
get your bridges in a stir that depth
play with the stairs is great first
things first do you have it it always
looks like she's standing on something
yeah the dep of the stairs was so clever
the mcness of it all we need to put this
package in that window it was his plan
meant to protect all of time she's so
much more sassy now he's dead what this
was the plan he made when he knew the
end was near for him oh man he didn't
watch this utter chaos he had a plan
okay who would
better yep totally blending in Steamboat
Miss minutes when he's back where he
belongs you and I will be right by his
side polyamorous relationship oh my God
lot of hands on that clock is that the
young version of him Victor
childly
oh what's in the
book hope this child knows how to read
how common was reading in the 1860s how
literate were we as a country did
audible existed yet could I listen to
this book Nick Offman Nar T handbook yes
yes amazing oh my God so if the timeline
Works where if you learn something you
remember it how much do throwing off the
sacred timeline work if he's delivering
knowledge that doesn't yet exist we
can't get in there and increase the
diameter of the Looms intake ring
include that knot of unrefined time wait
a second wait a second uh in English
please we need to scale the lom's
capacity to manage all those new
branches a thank God he spoken English
we can hack into the system really oh
that is such a relief I'm
wondering
tap it in the main frame OB what about
Miss minutes how are we going to find a
little rogue cartoon clock that doesn't
want to be found love these slow zooms
are
back it's like a monster approaching we
know Miss minut sent information to rer
and then we never saw her again the two
hits we had on the temp pad Trace it's
like a submarine movie but entire yeah
good call let's focus on that cartoon
clock they didn't call her a cartoon
before okay we got a hit on the temp pad
going from right here Chicago 1868 to
the same spot Shanghai
Noon I go that way you go this way I
mean this isn't a pivot point in history
any major figure rises from here like I
always got a green tie on let's go to
93 Ramona what are you up
to I like how his mustache fits in this
timeline very well a zoom and a track
cool what a transition that was
beautiful this is the outfits they wore
when they saw Victor timley Edison HH
Holmes yes air balloons HH holes
accomplished murderer if she has Mis
minutes there to help her there's
definitely a purpose for them going
there earlier but we just got to figure
it out it really hired all these extras
Liberty building debut on 4th of July
ghost clock I love how Mobius is
actually in costumes this time let me
see
that the name's chaplain charie chap
just that of sh I never got your name
name's chaplain Charlie chap Miss
minutes is right there ghost clock
continues to haunt Midway right exactly
that's affecting the sacred time right
yes get a little Irish cloth Chinese
Pavilion cool brief detail for
Refreshments yes yeah the crackerjack
concession stand there's a hi traffic
area it was necessary and
logical we get is the sightseeing I'm
not sightseeing listen we have different
styles he actually gets to explore this
time I take a more slow deliberate
cerebral approach because I see
everything I Noti this everything I love
how Mobius is actually becoming Owen
Wilson I
know all we need is an ohow wow oh man
oh oh you make your little homesick it's
completely inaccurate somebody feeling a
little left out that they're not up
there no why they include Boulder not
even heard of him they got Boulder bre
you know sometimes I forget that you're
one of them you are one of them one of
us offs my mind
[Music]
H wasn't
that might SL Victor fin
oh temporal
Marvels it's probably must be really
connecting to the Marvels you think it's
the second time they brought that word
up this is
[Music]
it no the game is a foot this feels like
a western Showdown
[Music]
what fun costumes and hair and
makeup really brought this to life there
she is it's so expensive it is expensive
yeah they should have just cged everyone
I mean yeah the volume's right there
scan all those extras is there not an AI
they could
use oh my God the scene the scene is
that balloon I think so time oh
every it moves through each and every
one of us he's a showman it shapes
Our Lives how is in the shadows
our
futures such Tom Hardy energy we can
shape
it it's
him
who he remains
ladies
[Music]
and sound like this terrifying
figure can I tell you that that plays so
much better to me yeah it really works
just what would you know about the
future boy oh oh boy and the answer is
more than
you might
think good pause there look where we are
I me to
see guys trying to pention to the show
energy of the past present and future
flows oh around us temporal
loon the electricity flowing through it
Gathering it into fine threads of time
power power which it then we Le okay
ropes
of voltage interesting in English please
a
chaos a chaos
transformed into order nice single B can
light genius the whole
of Chicago he's like the Tesla it's such
a different performance but so similar
to human genius the Showmanship now
makes a little bit more sense too I aim
to power the entire planet call it a
dream F laugh it off as pure science
fiction I love how this is always from
the audience's seat where you're seeing
him yeah our ey line all science is
fixing
until
it going to Blind him with
science
welcome wow welcome to is like wow wow
you're so
dominant you need to bring him back to
the TVA yeah you can't trust a variant
of he who remains in the TVA that's a
later problem we have a very serious now
problem they're doing it yep he just
described how to solve it is the only
thing that can get us access to the loom
and who knows what else he can do just
cut off one of his hands and take it
there I must have your temple Loom step
aside horn swagler I was here first oh
$1,000 that look I believe we have a a
deal wowe don't get mugged that is the
man who's destined to become he who
remains you sure your plan is going to
work the machine's not going to turn on
again God B hey I show you any physical
contact was purely
incidental interesting how about we
settle this
outside let's go
Lincoln I
agree wow the amazing Loki
everyone I need to talk with you about
something yes my future you walk and Tim
oh my excuse
me my and I would love to tell you about
a little business I beg your pardon
fellas you know who this is you all know
each other unfortunately your old friend
colle long time remember everyone just
touching you you're a confidence
trickster luminary is the word you're
looking
for a disruptor cruel technology of this
era to catch up with my Visionary mind
you know I never doubted it for a second
enlightened fellows never
do your inventions are fake oh no excuse
me oh
boy Huer Timely
I'm oh the pyramids this is where it
becomes
[Music]
Ramen there he is
go hiding behind one little pole there's
no escape from this Sky
f a thief in
here smart to do some of this in
unbroken
shots all right look CLE you're really
good at getting away we have that in
still me oh sh ah you stay out of
this just wait but when is she
from remember show had the temp pad
thing in the last episode yeah but I'm
wondering what is this directly after
that event we don't work together
anymore movus I don't have to tell you
anything it look we're not working
together scotcha you're a fugitive in
all of time what is going on we need him
without his help the TVA will be
destroyed good Let It Burn maybe this is
all part of the plan damn yeah I'm
really paranoid time VAR I know there
won't be a life to go back to and we
can't fix it without him I really do
wonder if he who remains this is part of
his domino effect yeah we need your help
no obious there is no we not anymore for
no time never imagine if this had come
out before Ant-Man H temporarily not
canon Antman oh
no
o where do you think he got that book if
you in the TVA hadn't messed with him oh
you're smart oh you're so smart Slayer
set him on a path that he wasn't meant
for you are waling him straight back
into the TVA damn you figured that all
out I didn't give him this book I was
shocked when I saw his face too maybe we
should throw him off this feris wheel
but we need him he just like a d I love
this music you haven't got a clue have
you what a beautiful cloth set but of
the time he may be our best hope of
saving them mean our Mis Min this is
very familiar isn't it I Can't Let Him
Live kill him right after he fixes the
Miss I you know I I might be on sylv's
side on this way oh my
God I feel like sylv's right but
everyone dies I really feel like this is
all part of he who remains big plan this
is your moment get him
moment
W
boo stay puffed
minutes so questions wow wow t on
bicycle absolutely not
adorable come on we need it it's almost
a jet ski you'll love this make yourself
comfortable this is where she falls in
love with him um
so oh oh my God she is Charmed by him
already yeah it's working but here
controls the temperature through the
cushion it's got a butt warmer oh
and a butt Chiller he invented The
Sharper Image so did you like my
performance back there
oo marvelous a bit creepy thank you
marvelous Miss men
excuse
Melle minutes so odd absolutely singular
well thank you you're pretty singular
yourself at least you will be are you
saying I created the
TVA I know this must be overwhelming I'm
going to be
rich it's like the story of my of my
myself always imagined is is
true did you hear the murder
part that is why you need me by your
side such intimacy I'll keep you
safe even before the TVA or her you
created me and we work together at the
end of time I know what a great man you
can become mm love him too I think so
weirdest love triangle ever arloom it's
in trouble that is not dissimilar to
what the wizard gentleman said to me on
the ferris wheel why AR the two of you
in cahoots with him and his
Butler time to
go in a timely fashion I do think
Jonathan Major's childish Wonder to all
this is really interesting stuff for
Victor timley and his same work with
dvon is really good too he's mine r b
oh Jacob she's out
[Music]
yours they're having so much fun with
the music anything nothing okay I'll
have B15 Runner trace this
way go stranger weirder season and shot
so much
darker I love that he has like a a Panic
Room I do like this reintroduction of
Victor timley of a good in attention man
like he's not cunning or evil I mean you
see yeah but he's not villainous what's
this latest work of yours it's so
important she's playing as the Moonlight
beautiful key to understanding and
manipulating type everything I've ever
imagined or that were imagined for me
she seems so enamored by him it was
delivered to
me and I have a child she might have
loved the concept of him before and then
met him or maybe an older version of
herself is getting some Nostalgia
subconscious feeling I've never found
out
who you I brought it to you you brought
it to him the way the postman brings the
post we both know whose plan it
was well whoever it was I thank you and
I hope they remain that I may thank them
too I like to think of it as a
correspondence between myself and the
Visionary very
auor I always knew my ideas were good
didn't have the technology to make them
really
work I'm rooting for you man I know
that's how you make K captivating you
have variance that
like multiple
facets thank you and what an actor's
dream to get to play so many versions
and to continue to do so indefinitely
starting to see the manual
become grab
it
yes appreciate that this Min looks so
peeed I have high hopes for this
partnership I could rule
[Music]
together o he doesn't want a part he
doesn't like partn said it
earlier it was all good till you said
that
[__] get on my
boat whoa W that was a sweet shot nicely
done oh wow you heard her Victor
partnership you had to do it oh bye miss
m there's that villainous side H wow
what an impulsive decision Rona that's
so messed up it really is I was like
dude just one come on all that find out
you were you are who you are because she
dropped off the book to you just like
should have said that word no don't like
my partner does capture that ego and
stubbornness though I have a um seat
float a float don't worry about
me yeah you can already see like the the
sketch of the TVA in here look at all
your amazing
work I'm so happy to be here really
laying on the sultry tone just wonderful
yes you have always been so smart Victor
is now what's the rush T's having so
much fun with this it might be smart to
lay low for a while we made quite the
Ruckus back there what is she trying to
seduce feels like I was worried that you
wouldn't come with me that you liked
raona better than me oh my god oh yeah
is there a sketch of made in that
journal
yours draw me like one of your French
girls when you first created me I was
just a simple AI just something to play
chess with I love that they're doing
this I could be more for you so you gave
me autonomy to write my own programming
Disney's her I was allowed to have wants
and follow whims and become who I am
you're the Creator each night we play
Jess and talk a loyal friend more than
friends oh there was one one whim you
never allowed me pleasure why didn't you
allow me a real
body yes yes if I had a body we could
truly lead together oh my God no
partnership like the evil version of
vision I don't know how to to do you
never even tried just standing in midst
a bunch of man bodies it's like Bride of
Frankenstein wanting to become the bride
yeah instead of what I could have been
your
girl yikes I love this so much so glad
they're doing this put that down don't
do this for you need me I love you wow
whoa It's like some weird Black Mirror
[__] yeah they better do it lovers
Tiff oh thank God yeah buddy things are
getting quite
straight you going to prune my boot my
dude oh my God the early days of pruning
I was entrusted with this Mission by he
who remains not his
variant I'm the one in
charge I am the captain now
miss R slay
off what are you
doing I mean is this the Free Will that
you were looking
for that is what she said at the end of
last EP last season I'm not leur I'm
bading after all those years of doing
your dirty work this guy's always caught
in a hostage
situation he just met all these people
we've all lost our way but someone has
to keep track of the big picture here
Loki holding power I'm the only one who
can bring stability to the TVA because
that's what I've been doing thanklessly
for eons wow you were dry away so you
star off a correlation order versus
chaos W I'm order is she going to PR him
let's get fascist
oh I'm
[Music]
chaos wow this is like a Terminator 2
situation yeah it is like miles Dyson
she's like Sarah Cotter she hunting him
through time I haven't done anything no
you will you will that that isn't me you
don't know
me you don't know the heart the heart I
I have beating in my chest Jesus this is
compelling I can make my
own choices Branch the to technically
can I'm not the man you think I am free
will fate her whole
[Music]
thing get him out of here oh yeah oh my
God they're bringing him to the
TVA this is crazy what a crazy plot turn
God
I mean that's what I thought would
happen but still cool it's happening
yeah don't make me regret
this we'll do our best and you leave her
to me yeah fight fight fight I suppose
I've been a box you've been wanting to
take for a long
time oof no that's painful I've killed
you a thousand times in my mind each
time more brutal than the
last it's crippling that kind of
obsession have you called him sick to
McDonald's you're going to get fired you
were working the next day you said so
it's power for you isn't it be careful
what you wish
for oh he still W put in the void oh
damn nice oh
oh oh my
God how Bleak together
forever that's great form of punishment
right right there wow get to be with
your ba away from that canivan clock
that is
[Music]
great how poetic love
it love you oh darn
darn foolish of him to make an enemy out
of someone who knows all his Secrets
really big one about you uhhuh I can
tell you but who's watching this it's
going to make you real
Angry
no
no no oh my goodness oh my goodness well
well well all right ladies and gentlemen
um listening to this on Apple and spot 5
we just watched Loki season 2 episode th
be sure to rate this we will talk about
it but before we do thank you to
everyone who is M www.re Nation shop
we're all wearing shirts available at
that store right now Coy's got a real
reject t on I got a purp Watchman
inspired who influences the influencers
John's got the citizen King one on and
we got a whole bunch of other te's as
well it is an amazing Immaculate way to
support the Channel show you a citizen
of the reject nation and the most proper
way look good while doing it thank you
guys so much means a lot for everyone
who's uh picked up a tea really really
because creatively involved in it so
means a lot anyway um who rated first
last time would you rate this uh I'm
going to go since I know we use decimals
now uh
8.9
okay I'm going to give this an
11.1 all
right uh LED it i' I'd actually meet you
at exactly an 8.0 D youc
yeah all right Co you can go first okay
um I I feel like this was what I wanted
the second episode to be I also feel
like this is
exactly what I wanted gang to be I'm a
little I'm kind of struggling with
Ant-Man existing in my head right now
because I I know uh ant I like ants uh
but I know it's going to upset people
that enjoy Ant-Man and you please enjoy
what youy that defense is all over
Twitter now all people are like Ant-Man
fa life you guys don't get it and that's
what it is it's full of he didn't
actually get taken out by don't you see
fought SK no I he was weakened by but a
man that is the coner of time was even
affected by ants so we didn't get killed
affected by ants ants who advanced their
their civilization thousands of years
off screen off screen I like ants okay
Honey I Shrunk the kid should not have
as much Vin diagram and taken out Kang
as anyway anyway I think that in my head
Cannon the Ant-Man timeline has been
pruned and this is now what follows Loki
season 1 in any way of having Kang the
beauty of Kang is it is the actor's
dream role it is a a villain that is the
visual representation of duplicities it
is someone whose Duality is every bit of
the character as well as time it is the
use of time and space it is the use of
an actor playing someone with that much
multiversal and and internal
conflict and I think that Jonathan maor
is one of the great actors of our time
uh and there was definitely some Bronson
Tom Hardy that I enjoyed in that stage
performance but he played he who remains
in a similar way to Victor timley that
was completely theatrical but in in a
time period it worked and then Kang was
differently theatrical but in a somber
way because he was a Kang that had been
trapped and those three performances are
just the beginning of what Kang can be
in shape out personally I didn't love
the writing of how they had K but I did
enjoy what majors brought to the
performance of the now not head can and
Ant-Man movie I do think however this
delivery allows for there to be the Kang
Dynasty's impact of having a a series of
kangs that you can feel for against and
for because now that Kang can do
horrible things and we've met Victor
timley who does have that childlike
wonder and innocence who does have that
impact of someone you can see what they
just wanted to do but still can do evil
things like just disavow someone who
literally caused their success someone
that is able to be Tesla but also Edison
um so I loved that element but I did
struggle a little bit with the um the
reason it's not a nine or higher is the
tone um there were moments that felt uh
a bit disi um there were moments that
were like let's make sure this is also
High jinxy fun because of the dark tone
there were a couple moments that did
feel like it was a borderline slap stick
that if this was a slapstick show would
have fit but there is a there's a
difference between mischievous and
playful which I think that both Heston
Wilson and uh Majors do well but then
you have the directing and the editing
like have like and it almost got to like
where I was expecting them to run in
circles and play like old British music
like it it it got a little much Hill in
there yeah thank you that was what I was
looking for uh it didn't quite mesh with
the rest so it can't be a nine because
that's approaching perfect but all the
story advance
all the exposition all the performances
all the delivery all of the fixes that I
had issues with episode 2 were here I
just had some tone stuff yeah I think I
I know what you're talking about because
I think the intention is very clear of
wanting to emulate period pieces older
like so much of as compared to season 1
there's a lot of cinematic influences of
other eras in this season and I I think
Theo choice and the intention is very
obvious that they wanted to emulate kind
of what you know those those old timey
uh kind of uh humorous angles would
happen and with that kind of quirkiness
and stuff and intent is one thing and
overall um execution is another hunt for
out October worked that didn't like you
know what I mean that scene felt like a
submovie but we didn't go oh that's
distracting like this was a little much
yeah that I I understand what they were
going for uh with that Whimsy but at
times for just for my taste yeah it
wasn't quite meshing for me either um it
didn't quite tickle me in the way I
think it it wanted to but damn a B minus
B+ a minus like I I want the positives
to shine because I I agree and I think
this was a leap back from episode one
like one was like that 98 two dropped
for me this is back yeah and I I love
what they're doing because you know when
you first say that King is going to be
your big baddy for going into the next
couple phases of Marvel
you kind of have this preconceived idea
of just another like oh big threat yeah
big threat and you're starting to get a
bigger you're trying to get a better
impression of of what it is of watching
the creation of something like there's I
like the I like the tangibility of hope
that oh maybe there's a way we can
prevent it yeah what if free will like
you know you're having that moment with
Victor timley at the end I'm like that's
not like this is this is the he's not
Nathaniel Richards but he is the Kang of
of our of the Sacred timeline like there
maybe there's a hope here of maybe we
can use this guy maybe to fight the
other versions you know yeah like there
maybe there's a chance we could learn
from him maybe he won't turn bad but you
really don't know you really don't know
because at the end of the day like
that's why I love the decision that they
made where he does drop raona into the
water because you're like but there's
that there's a bad guy in him there's
still a v there's still a narcissist in
this dude there's still a villain within
him like can we trust him and that's
that paranoia that I love because they
set up at the very beginning too Miss
minut saying that there's this like I
don't forget who exactly essentially
there's like a contingency plan that if
he who remains were to die here's what
he would want to happen which is again
the the Gess of of uh the deceit of um
of of of he who remains where he
presented to Loki and Sylvie that kill
me you rule you can rule this it all all
could be chaos or you know uh but he had
a plan in mind the whole time in case so
I'm like are we just watching his plan
play out right now if he hadn't been
killed would he have gotten on the
sacred timeline that book like that
element yeah that's what I mean it's
like he he he's still playing some
domino effect in a way of possibly
Conjuring up some resurrection of
himself yeah you know and I think it's
brilliant it's it because I you don't
you just don't know you have no idea and
even though some of that quirkiness so
what they were attempting to emulate was
not really driving with me I love when
they do decide to go stranger with it
like everything with Miss minutes her
weird obsession with wanting to become
like human anatomy I love it absolutely
love it because it is
uncomfortable it's um it's sexual in a
way without being uh you
know graphic but it's still like strange
and unsettling yeah because she want she
wants him ter strong killing it too like
that performance was all her I love it I
love it so much sexy disembodied clock
yeah I think that's great I do have and
and I love like Loki and and Mobius uh
them bonding together everything that
like I love the different shades we
getting amobia we didn't get the bike I
wanted the bike bike sorry um end of the
season and again yeah again the set
pieces are are absolutely awesome and
ravona I think
I think ra like what's like you know
you're talking about like duality of
things with ravona and MOB oh man that
ended with Rono so much happened in this
episode with
like Rona obviously doesn't want
everything to collaps either she doesn't
want the the ex existence to come to an
end so there is paths that they have
goals that they have that are similar
but yet so different at the same time
and and um I think my one thing that
that I am wondering about the show if
it's still gonna if it's going to bother
me it's might sound
odd it's
Loki Loki kind of just seems
like a TVA agent with superpowers now I
think that's why they gave him Powers is
like give him stuff to do and I'm
missing a little bit of his personality
of his personal Journey that might have
also why they let the Brad scene play
the personal Journey the
personality it's it's some of that is
not seeming as much of a it's called
Loki at the end of the day yeah and and
at the same time like I get he went
through a character
Arc uh but there does seem to be
something like Tom H it's weird it's the
the complexity of I think Tom Hon's
killing it and anchors it with what he's
what he's giving yeah but it is just so
straight forward with him and I am
missing I I I'm kind of like everyone
else is like seems like they're getting
such great development which is awesome
like I love that I just wish it was also
in conjunction with Loki like the season
twos are often that right where at
season one you have your character
season two you build the sporting but
then at the end of season you well yeah
but nothing's perfect except but then at
the end of season two you see the arc
that's been the slowburn like like the
Bear right like the have you seen the
bear no okay well the bear is a great
example I've Seen Better Call Saul
Breaking Bad those you know excuse me
for Citizen Kane over here I'm sorry I'm
sorry good Fellas and The Godfather were
taking there are
shows youate that you you would very
much enjoy it as a creative person of
all Stripes you would love it and that
does it John knows what I'm saying the
second season how they do that thing
where the whole rest of the cast you
think is rising and then at the end you
realize that their Rising has caused the
shift in the lead and you go oh the at
the end of the second season is now was
about all of them not just the support
so they do that I just rewatched it
that's that's in my mind but I think the
show was going to do that where Tom
Hon's Arc is going to really shine
episodes four five and six okay that's
my hope because right now it has just
been very um that that is that is the
one thing that is like kind of missing
for me well he hasn't not been there
like the scene in the pie place we we
talked about the reversal we talked
about like the scene with Brad like
there have been elements but I do see
where we're talking about everyone but
him you're not wrong yeah we're we're
not talking about and like it's Tom hson
he's a force like it's not him it's just
whatever everyone else is also having to
do yeah yeah everyone else has the much
more interesting stuff happen and he's
just kind of the plot device to keep
things going along yeah and and that is
a that that's something that I am
correct but sorry John I kind of just
derailed this no it's okay I mean your
points my Ral rating was what 11.1 and
you said that that brought me down to
like a
10.8 and then what you just said brought
me down to like a 10.2 you know so
like I mean yeah no everything you guys
are are saying I I I at least I'm not
affected the same way by all these
things but I do acknowledge that they're
there like yeah especially in the middle
of the episode with all the different
guys chasing timely around who've all
been bamboozled like it's very of the
time but it is like an interlude you
don't necessarily need but that adds you
know just like extra kind of chaos to
everything I was fine with that but yeah
I I get why maybe that would be
something where you're like ah can we
get back to the point because just turn
the music down sure and and with Loki
certainly this is the episode where of
the three it feels the least centered
around his actual character so much as
you know there's more interesting stuff
for yeah the The Supporting Cast to do
learn experience Etc uh so in light of
that I would put the first episode at
the top because it's all these things
it's the weird it's the Intrigue it's
lowkey and then the second episode I
would rank third so far because it's
still like lowkey and it's still about
the relationships and and his tension
with Sylvia and all that and this is
very much like a functional episode for
him but what I thought this really did
nicely was like I forgot about time
while I was watching this this felt like
a substantial little movie of an episode
and I thought it really well committed
to its time and place and used it richly
whereas last episode I was like ah it
feels like some of these things could
have been utilized and explored more
richly this is like no we did our you
know 19th century Chicago episode they
understood the importance of this
episode that's a great point I didn't
feel like we cared about the 80s uh and
that would have been fun like an ' 80s
actor episode and then and then an 1800
Chicago episode you're right the setting
here was great yeah and it's like it it
it uses this sort of World's Fair
aesthetic and it uses the Tesla you know
Edison like all those trappings that are
fun and are of the time the genre of the
place are really well utilized here and
everything kind of seemed to serve some
level of purpose and so even having all
those hyinks I was like well that's
adding at least to
a Chase that's already ensuing between
all the main characters too um and yeah
I love that they decided and found time
and means within an episode like this
that is again getting back to the main
villain uh they they just found time for
so many great debates and questions and
that's not something I'm as used to in a
Marvel uh and that I thought was lovely
here because obviously the the most rich
one is I loved Sylvie facing down with
him sword to his neck and him being like
I I haven't made these choices like
throwing her argument back at her and I
thought this episode was a great sort of
catapulting of different arguments back
and forth you've got ravona and Mobius
kind of going in a similar Direction but
for entirely different motivations and I
thought that was really tangible and
lovely and like her presence I thought
even though she is you know amidst all
this chaos I think uh it's gooo and baar
ra right like she's got a lovely
presence even still and I'm still
interested in seeing her and how that
continues and even what her weird
relationship with Miss m is now that
Miss Min clearly has her own motivation
and that was a thing where I'm like we
don't have to do this and it's Disney
it's kind of a weird thing to be doing
but I'm glad we're doing it because it's
all part of the possibility of this
strange little world and uh and and yeah
I thought this was a well proportioned
episode and I thought it did all the all
the things I love from sci-fi kind of in
one big pot you know it's got sci-fi fun
and games but it's got a lot of like
weird
uncomfortable situations that that now
we get to think about because of these
extraneous circumstances and it's also
got the personal stuff the heft of the
journey for somebody like Sylvie but
also like the real question of like yeah
it seems like we're backed into a corner
where the only solution is either bring
Victor timely back or somehow strong our
Mis minutes into doing this and so
either way we're in kind of a bad
position here so you know we got to
choose the lesser of two evils and yeah
I don't know I just thought all of that
was really acious and really you know
easy to get swept up in and yeah it was
fun in games but also like nice and
cerebral and odd and emotional too so
I'm I'm gonna go back to I'm gonna go to
r nine you just you tip me up one that
that point one I'm at I'm at 90 now
because of the setting Point that's a
really good point so yeah I think this
was exceptional like this was it's not
quite the perfect near perfect I thought
the first was but this was really good
like this feels like what I wanted
lowkey season 2 to be when season one
ended like this using time using space
using Kang building out phase I would
have thought of this as phase four
before they I think early ended phase
four but this this phase four time and
space continuum situation and it does
feel like it's going to lead nicely to
what I assume Deadpool 3 and King
Dynasty are um ravona was in in that
recording in that first episode ravona
sounded like she W they were Partners at
one point yes and is that what Miss
minutes was going to convey oh that's a
good point that you guys were does
happen you've already gotten what you
wanted in the past or something or in a
different scenario because it it seems
like they were partners and then he he
had the whole thing of like never mind
I'm going to wipe your memory now you're
just the main judge you know yeah um
that'd be interesting that'd be that
would piss her off like he you you had
power and then it was taken from you
sorry yeah so we've already this I think
they're good ide do at least we've lived
this and you lost yeah cuz she is in a
loop of bringing him back the TV already
if there's a double Loop of like
everything you fight for is for not mhm
oh God and dropping her off with like
his decomposing body oh man that was
dark yeah yeah I mean to for my money
this is still the best show like can
seeing Loki as a whole like this is you
know what I just realized too of why I
think some of that Quirk didn't work for
us because the show did not change how
[__] dark
physically 1800 lights I was
like it's still like shot with this like
super dark cinematographer I did I was
looking for like AJ Holmes in the
background like are they going to do a
murder in the background are we going to
go to the murder hotel is the hotel in
theory so it didn't quite compliment the
visual aesthetic that to us till the
very end of this to get there but I
think that's what clicked for me the fan
I loved it I couldn't Place why I loved
it you're right it was work it till like
300 or 4 in the morning every day this
week guys so like I have a very delayed
tra of thought on everything okay but
yeah that is the that I think you're
right cuz the fan fair I loved and I was
like this is perfect and then at the end
I was like not quite magic here yeah and
that's what it was I wanted to see the
magic yeah felt like we were at
disneylander world on a set and they
were playing that music and I was like
I'm uncomfortable like it just felt like
Disney was telling me how to feel yeah
yeah but man nine man a nine yeah man um
but yeah guys uh
look um look look listen everyone's got
um everyone's got opinions um I'm GNA
I'm sticking with my my 8.9 um we're all
in a very Sim I think there is just some
I do think that at times the pacing of
this like from second episode of this
one there there are some just off things
I think about its pacing that it it it
can just like I don't know how to
describe it and and honestly I got a
level with you guys um I don't often
like using this as some excuse I have
been very sleep deprived all week and I
do think that sometimes I can affect
like the way I I intake a a certain kind
of Oddity with the with the way
something is paced I'm not I'm not using
that as an excuse to be like actually
it's great it's just just just me it
could beat the show itself I I don't
know it's all subjective at the end of
the day can I Lev a conspiracy theory
yeah what if maybe this was intended to
be like episode two and then all this
[__] went down and they were like uh
let's let's wait till later in the
season to get to Jonathan Majors let's
let's cram something else in there first
let's put moraa in there cuz it did feel
like two was like extended and put in in
a spot yeah it feel like extended and
truncated and and kind of like it could
have fit elsewhere and everything
they're saying about
Loki I'm now I'm in the tired uh defend
your negative criticism thing even
though I'm like mainly super positive
8.9 why isn't this an 11 for that weird
Loop in my own head uh you pre the
comments yeah when you work so much on a
video you can't you see like a couple of
negative comments that like the GRE who
remains the future killing these C it's
the Lo Loki I think
I think everything they've presented
about him is just repetitive from what
they've already done with in season one
like even everything Brian was saying to
him in the second episode I'm like we've
already done this
uh yeah and uh same thing with like the
little tidbits here where R vot's like
you can't trust that guy and I'm like
that's not really part of the character
Arc uh but at the same time yeah I I
think there's just like we need
something new with with you know how
tired Greg is he just confidently called
rapael casselle Brian when his name is
Brad but you said it with such fervor
you're like what name Brian were talking
not Brian definitely Brad hey you're
tired like that proves the tiredness of
this man he was like forgot a white guy
name just like H hide my tiredness all
week until this like the last five
minutes of this video I'm I'm really
enjoying that on a time travel show
future Greg is like I don't want to read
those comments so if past Greg has to
say some stuff to subvert those comments
I'm going to read
later those people already type those
comments and turn off the video before
they even heard I think they have them
in a note they just copy and paste once
the video posts they watch the video
they've got their comments planned out
for the whole season they Mad Lib they
just mad lib insults they're like we're
going to put it in here and there's that
one guy that's like get koyi off the
channel and he just saves them and puts
in different ad oh my God I saw the
funniest funniest comment about you God
my favorite comment um I think it was on
a gen V1 oh no which was uh Coy's the
kind of guy who claps when the plane
lands
that is so funny I like that so
much clapping I'm a Clapper I you know I
fly too much for that I'm very we should
all be clapping when a plane lands it's
magic magic we just hurdled in a tube
through the sky we just hope we land
okay he's got a clap what a PL lands
actually that does serve the way I see
the world we're getting all of this it's
a gift so yeah I'm a clap I'm happy
we're here statistically it's still the
safest way to travel it is statistically
Superman guys when I take off my seat
Bel I clap too cuz I made it there I got
there in the car way to travel I'm just
like yeah when I Dismount my bicycle I
CL myself I get off my long board I'm
like done did it anytime I'm roller
skating skateboarding any across a major
intersection from Li I'm clapping on the
lime scooter you should see me read a
book every flip man someone wrote that I
really enjoyed that
page all righty guys well thank
you everyone claps when that happens
anyway we should clap with when we get
to the end of the
video see you guys for Pat the day shout
out all right guys well we got to catch
up on some shout outs here because
there's only so many days left in the
months we got to shout out two patrons
and we have discovered that artificial
intelligence chat TBT is a brilliant
writer in its own mind so we wanted to
bring to life the fantasy of two patrons
that we know if they met each other in
person what it might go down like during
this spooky season season time
definitely so John please pick a couple
names who do you got who do we know who
we gotten to know let's do uh male Lyon
and let's do uh Chris whof all right
kale Lyon and Chris whof yeah all right
okay perfect all righty um okay we got
this we're good I got this so I'm gonna
say uh I need you to create a scene of
two characters just want the dialogue a
sticker coma if if you will here's their
personalities and have them meeting each
other or catching up while bumping into
one another during trick-or-treating but
let's spice it up really make it
intense and and something out of a
horror
movie but make sure to incorporate all
these things that I'm going to list
about their personality traits yes of
course got to be comprehensive okay all
right so uh Chris Wham off how how would
you describe him selfless individual
selfless individ or just some facts
about him he's been arrested for
fighting the good fight yes yes he he
makes good trouble uh he's uh to be
found at a protest sticking up for the
little man likely to be found at a
protest sticking up for the the little
man he's a charitable guy uh charitable
individual also a bit of a movie geek as
well you'd hope so being here being here
it's just like a de facto character
type uh lives in the midwest I think for
this story you live in the midwest lives
in the midwest yeah and what are just
the things we imagine about him that
maybe we don't know for sure okay like
he's a I think he's a fast runner he's a
fast runner uh slow reader slow reader
real ladies has trouble sleeping gets l
like nobody's business yes all right I
love it John I love it okay now male
Lyon M Lyon all right obviously from
Sweden Swedish obvious to break down for
them obviously from Sweden yes
absolutely loves James Bond
movies um that's really the only two
things we know about we've been milking
that for years he's a classy guy classy
guy um I would say like major Bookworm
major book yeah super into science yes
thought Robert Oppenheimer was
correct um sure just about all the it
just yeah about
every considered voting for Donald
Trump um these are things that I just
imagine about you m tot even though he
couldn't legally because he's in Sweden
he has a drag Alter Ego yeah drag Alter
Ego
um consider Thanos was right yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah he sides with secretly
watches every Mel Gibson movie after
post his arrest yes only that period of
Mel and uh and he's a big as riller fan
as well and big aser Miller fan and um
often quotes and recites the Christian
Bale
rant when out
of words in an argument oh make sure you
include the word rant there so it knows
where to Source this this gold for us
Christian Bale Terminator Salvation
onset rant all right let's see let's see
how good of it watch guys we're about to
see magic happen the future is here all
right let's see what it generates okay
okay here we go oh my goodness setting
oh let really thinking about this one a
desolate Midwestern Street the last rays
of sunlight disappearing the thick fog
rolling in obscures Vision making the
evening even even more eerie the
occasional hoot of an owl or rustling of
leaves is all that breaks the silence
the scene is set for a chilling
Halloween night I'll be Chris all right
suddenly bump into a tall finger
catching damn sorry man this fog's no
joke you're all right adjusting his
collar with a slight Swedish accent just
do a British accent I'm fine you should
watch where you're going but then again
I lost in uh I'm going to try it I'm
fine you should watch where you're going
but then again I was lost in thought
about oppenheimer's contribution to
science a tragic genius that one huh I'm
more fighting for the hear and now like
sticking up for the little
guy genius genius replacing everyone
this is what this with the writer Tri
fought against definitely protests Ries
that sort of thing uh o i Man of Action
but even in action one must know when to
speak and when to listen even at ever
hear Christian Bales rant on set of
Terminator Salvation that's me when I'm
at the loss for words I can't say I've
heard it I'm more of a movie geek so I'm
not likely to hear this Christian Bale
R nothing to do with movies so let's so
in the celebrity drama that sounds
intense oh it is much like the intensity
of James Bond's missions are you a fan
I've always been drawn to his world I've
seen a few but hey if you want intensity
try running at top speed through the
Midwest field Shields the wind in your
face and the thrill of freedom in your
chest who running away or running
towards
something sometimes I don't even know
sleep doesn't come easy to me ah the
burden of a Restless mind I often find
solace in books but even then sometimes
my thoughts wander like considering the
perspective of someone like Thanos
sounds heavy Thanos huh can't say I
agree with him but hey we have all our
controversial opinions I mean I mean I
get quite some attention from the ladies
but it doesn't make me any more
understood ah the age-old struggle I
myself considered voting for Trump once
but let's not delve into politics
instead tell me are you familiar with
that Miller's or I can't say I've seen a
lot but Mel Gibson that's a name been
secretly catching up on his stuff post
arrest secrets on Halloween how fitting
and speaking of Secrets let's just say
that in some circles not always known as
migale sounds mysterious but hey we all
have our secrets so makes the night like
this even more intriguing the two men
with their differing views and
mysterious auras continue down the foggy
Street the atmosphere charged with the
weight of their conversation and the
unknown horrors of Halloween night look
these shout outs might take way longer
to do but the time
exponentially
yes it is worth every second this this
was ripped out of real life Wow Wow we
have every right to fear and and put
precautions in place yeah now is the
time because I could see a screenwriter
taking this material and adapting it m
yeah it's drawing from everywhere across
the internet how can you beat that plus
with directions as clear as these and
everything like it's going to be
spitting out scripts in all
time for Vi Chris love you guys
[Music]